Happy thanksgiving, sweetheart.
I have to go out
for a bit today.
You take your meds?
Your mother's death
was a terrible loss
to endure at your age.
I think you're afraid
because the man
who did this was never caught.
And maybe that's why
you don't want to leave.
I'm safe here.
You can't stay in here forever.
A teenager from
California is still
missing after a one-week
search has failed to turn
up any new leads or witnesses.
Hey, where did you get
my birthday present?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's blood on this.
This whole thing is
getting out of hand.
You're paranoid.
Don't turn this around on me.
All I have is us.
You think I want to lose you?
I'm afraid that's all the
time we have for today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]